Yeah,
reproductive success is at the center of natural selection and it's therefore no
surprise that evolutionary thinking plays a big role in how we look at
reproduction is an aspect of evolutionary medicine.
We're going to start by seeing the history of the Mammalian reproductive tract.
Yeah.
The youth therians,
the mammals that have a long gestation period with a well-developed placenta
have a reproductive system that is an evolutionary innovation
in females.
It's derived from ancestral Oregon's that previously had produced eggs that
exited through a Clo Waco.
The innovations include the uterus,
the endometrium,
the placenta,
and the vagina.
Okay.
These innovations are accomplished by changes in the developmental control of
cells and tissues and in this case,
the genes that are used to control developmental fates in the reproductive tract
had previously evolve to control the development of the body axis and the limbs,
and so that's where we're going to start.
Okay.
Now,
the key issue in development is how to coordinate what many different cell types
are becoming.
If we go back in the history of biology,
the fact that organisms are built out of cells is something we've known since
1839 that's this fond schleiden cell hypothesis.
Yeah.
These cells communicate with each other.
They send and receive information on their spatial location and they use that
information to change their cell fates.
That is what they differentiate into.
Yeah.
So virtually all cells in the eukaryotic body contain all the information
necessary to produce the entire organism.
The only reason we say virtually is that we have a few cells like the red blood
cells that do not contain a nucleus.
Yeah.
And therefore development is controlled by regulating gene expression,
not by discarding genes in order to get different tissue types.
Yeah.
Much of treat evolution has changed when and where genes are expressed and not
the DNA sequences of structural genes.
We're going to see a good example of that when we look at the Mammalian
reproductive tract.
Okay.
So what does development actually do in evolution?
It shapes the variation in the genome that gets presented to selection.
The developmental mechanisms that are shared among related organisms constrain
the responses to selection in ways that are shared by relatives.
That's why species resemble shared ancestors and basic body plans.
And that is why ancestry influences responses to selection.
To think about that.
Uh,
a fruit fly has wings and six legs and it will respond to selection on its
ability to fly or to walk in quite a different way than a bird that has two
wings and two legs.
Now genes build organisms out of materials that are interacting in complex
systems and those materials have to obey the laws of physics and chemistry.
So genes have to work with the properties of those materials in constructing a
phenotype.
They can't directly control every detail of the phenotype.
So we shouldn't imagine that you tations are able to change things in arbitrary
ways.
They can't,
they are handed a set of systems and materials and they have to work with it.
Evolution has shaped the properties of developmental systems by working with
what they got from it's from ancestors.
Okay.
So they modify existing systems and that is done by working with whatever
variance are available at the time.
So not necessarily the best option,
simply the best of those available.
Thus,
evolution doesn't design organisms.
Apriori is would an engineer.
It designs organisms in a process of sequential approximation.
Now
the major players in gene regulation are sketched here in this figure
transcription is going to begin here and the DNA that will be coding for a
protein is going to be laid down off here to the right,
just upstream of it.
There's an enhancer sequence and a promoter sequence and the gene is turned on
or off by transcription factors and enhancers that bind to these sequences.
So these are being produced,
uh,
their proteins,
they're being produced by other genes that are regulating the expression of this
gene.
And you can see that depending upon what combination of transcription factors
this particular gene gets,
it will be turned on or off.
Once it is turned on,
the RNA polymerase starts walking down the DNA double helix,
making messenger RNA.
So
gene expression is not only controlled by transcription factors,
it's also controlled by acetylation which to which will uh,
Wa unwind the DNA from the histones on around which it is wrapped or bind it to
those histones.
So acetylation can uncover large,
large stretches of DNA and methylation is a bit more specific.
It can a bind just to one gene and prevent it from being expressed.
And then there's also phosphorylation of histone tails that will activate or
repress chromatin.
So on a spatial scale,
genes can be silenced or expressed either over large stretches,
intermediate stretches,
or just a single genes.
Okay.
A few general points
at the beginning of development,
usually in the egg,
a concentration gradient is giving positional information so it will determine
which is going to be the head in which is going to be the tail,
which is going to be next to the body,
which will be far away from the body and which will be the back in which will be
the stomach,
anterior,
posterior and dorsal lateral dorsal ventral
transcription factors in histone regulation.
Then define specific areas of the genome who are precise.
Subset of genes is expressed.
Gene expression importantly is often regulated by combinations of activators and
repressors.
This is important because it means that a limited number of activators and
repressors can be put into different combinations to generate many,
many more possible targets for activation or silencing this common tutorial
control then permits a huge diversity of cell specific gene expressions.
Yeah.
Jeez.
That produce transcription factors are regulated by genes that produce
transcription factors.
So there is a hierarchy of transcriptional control.
The same genes that play one role in the embryo can play another role in the
adult.
And this is one of the mechanisms that underlies ply a trophy.
Yeah.
Genes that control the general patterns switch on first and then genes
controlling progressive layers of detail.
One of the important sets,
not the only one,
but one of the important sets of developmental control genes are called the
hawks are homeobox genes.
They are deeply conserved.
That means that,
uh,
we can see because they are shared by many different organisms that they
originated long ago and they have,
they have retained their function.
And their sequence on chromosomes.
They have an interesting property of being colinear.
What that means is that the sequence on the chromosome is analogous to the part
of the body in which that gene is turned on or off to express a certain pattern.
Okay,
so the anterior genes are coming here on the left,
the ones that are controlling the central part of the body or in the middle and
the ones that are controlling the development of the rear of the body are
expressed here on the right.
This is a tree and it shows that the genes that are expressed in the anterior of
Drosophila are also expressed in the anterior of worms and of mice and of sea
urchins.
So this is a very ancient set of genes.
Here we can see an embryonic fruit fly and an embryonic mouse and you can see
that the hawks be one gene which is controlling the hindbrain of the mouse is
homologous to the lab gene,
which is controlling the formation of the brain of the sly and so forth.
You can see going back through the body.
The sequence of hawks genes in the mouse is in the same linear sequence as the
genes in the,
in the body of the fly.
Now duplicating this set of genes,
preserve their control function and it allowed new applications.
So in the lineage which leads up to the vertebrates,
the hocks gene complex was duplicated twice.
Along with the whole genome,
we actually have,
uh,
had to duplication events of our genome.
So we can see here both in the fore limb and the hind limb that Hawk's genes
nine 10,
11,
12,
and 13 are controlling limb structure.
And if nine and 10 are on,
basically it is saying make a humorous.
If 10 and 11 are on,
it's saying make a radius and Alma and if 11,
12 and 13 are on it saying make risks and digits.
And similarly in the hind limb,
so
evolution took advantage of the existence of a developmental switch and a set of
developmental rules for gene expression that originally had been set up to
control the body axis,
head thorax,
tail.
And when the vertebrate limb came along and it was being developed out of
precursors that were fins in the fish,
it's simply took that and took a duplicate copy of it and use the same kind of
set of rules to lay down a sequence in the limb.
That is like the sequence of the body axis.
Okay.
Now let's take a look at the female reproductive system.
We needed all of that history to set up this neat thing about the developmental
control of the female reproductive system in you therians.
It is radically different from monotremes and other amnios.
So the monotremes or the duck billed platypus is in the spiny a kid knows.
Then we have the marsupials and we have the placentals and as we go from the
amphibians through birds and reptiles to monitor seems to Marsupial's to
placentas.
You can see that we go from having a [inaudible] to having a vagina and then
finally to having a well developed uterus,
uh,
which is quite a distinct set of organs that look really considerably different
from what we had in say something like a monitoring.
So if we look at that in terms of timing and in history,
the first thing that happened is that there was reduced reliance on yoke and
there were some uterine secretions.
Then the Cloaca was divided,
so there was a vagina and uh,
a rectum
so that those became separate,
separate entrances or exits.
Uh,
the Avo docs differentiated self,
the shelf formation to make eggs stopped,
the uterus developed and began to nourish embryos.
And the placenta originated that we share with marsupials.
And then in the placentals mammals like us,
the youth Ariens,
the
plus the uterus and the placenta were elaborated,
the embryo became invasive and there was a longer period of internal
development.
When we look at the genes that control the you in female reproductive tract,
we find some very familiar actors.
Hawks nine,
10,
11 and 13.
So when a hawks,
a nine is switched on,
the Fallopian tubes are formed.
When hawks a 10 is switched on,
the upper uteruses formed a 11 is the lower uterus and a 13 is determining the
vagina.
So these are now controlled by the hawks genes that are in the first set.
And earlier in development.
These are the same genes that laid down the body axis.
Yeah.
So they also have some other functions,
hocks eight,
10 and 11.
Downregulate the immune system in the endometrium that helps the uh,
Zygote to implant and hawks a 10 is also involved in endometrial maturation and
in Zygote attachment a 11 in an endometrial maturation and a 13 in the umbilical
arteries.
So the point is that a preexisting set of developmental switches was co opted
and used to help in the evolution of a novelty.
It was expressed in a new new place and uh,
this is all done through transcriptional factor control of gene expression.
Now interestingly,
one of the innovations that developmental control was caused by the insertion of
a Transposon,
we previously saw that the insertion of a transpose on was a critical step in
the evolution of the vertebrate immune system is what brought in the machinery
that allows for sematic recombination here.
This transposon inserted upstream from a target gene bringing other jeans under
control of that transcription factor.
And in this case and endometrial stromal cells,
the transcription of prolactin is controlled by an enhancer.
That's derived from a transposon murder 20 that invaded the mammalian genome
when placentation evolved.
So we're talking about something in the region of perhaps 90 to 120 million
years ago.
That insertion then rewired a large genetic network.
When we look at the expression patterns,
we can see that there are about 1,500 genes that were recruited into endometrial
expression and placental mammals.
13% of them are within about 200 kilobytes kilobases of murder 20 this
transposon,
which binds the transcription factors that are essential for pregnancy and
regulates gene expression in response to progesterone and to see cyclic amp.
So this is one way that an innovation can occur in evolution.
A transpose on can come in and it is carrying with it a binding site for
transcription factor and if that will insert upstream from a series of other
genes,
some of which can be cooled coating for transcription factors that results in
the rewiring of a genetic network.
So to summarize,
the female reproductive tract develops under the control of the same genes that
earlier had laid down in the body axis.
This is an evolutionary innovation.
It required the rewiring of a large genetic network,
and some of the innovation was made possible by the insertion of a transposable
element,
carrying receptors for transcription factors.